I'm trying on Skate
Sho skatebo I actually used to
skateboard but I was not very good if
that's any consolation so maybe we try
it even harder I will I'll
try I am not
good
thanks you guys are so good at
cheating well my mom she has really
really big feet do you think it would
fit
her very big feet my mom's feet are
bigger than yours like
seriously she's like a
monster
I don't really know if my mom should be
skating or
not t buying skate shoes he just bought
skate
shoes offal how do you feel right
now pretty fabulous me too get not that
easy oh look he's he's do a lot better
than I did you've been practicing
haven't
you don't fall in traffic
this